you are watching the press preview a
first look at the front pages as they
arrive
in the next half an hour we'll be taking
look at what's making the headlines with
these two the consultant editor of the
daily mail andrew pearce and the
associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin maguire but
let's take a quick look at a couple of
the front pages
before all of that starting with the
metro carrying the findings
of a report which alleges that at the
start of the pandemic
more than 3.7 billion pounds in
taxpayer-funded contracts for ppe were
handed out to companies
led by close allies of conservative
politicians
the express hears that no covert cases
have resulted from a trial event
at the world snooker championships in
sheffield which played host to a
capacity crowd
and the mail meanwhile says that
thousands more families will suffer
unless the rules surrounding funerals
are revised
here's the mirror it leads on the
queen's message of thanks for all the
tributes paid
to prince philip
the italian prime minister mario draghi
is poised to accept a 221 million euro
grant from the eu's pandemic recovery
fund
according to the ft
the telegraph spies a story about mi5
joining social media
in an effort to be more open
and the star well it's carrying a story
about marmite
as opinions are likely to be split over
a shortage of the
absolutely wonderful foodstuff
and from marmites to andrew pearce and
kevin maguire i'm sure our audiences
have a view
on both of you gentlemen it's lovely to
see you this evening um and we will
start straight away uh
with well the story of the past couple
of days really the the super league and
that early bath in the front of the ft
who wants to kick off today
yeah neil early bath for the super
league that's probably as racial
headline as you'll get
in the uh financial times but of course
they cover it because of the
the business side but it is amazing as
you say it
dominated for several days and it's
completely collapsed
now and as john henry and liverpool
their
owner joel glazer at manchester united
issue apologies
you could just see the gap that opened
between the very
wealthy people owning some of uh
britain's most
famous historic loved football clubs
and their their fans and it was a
victory for fan
power that this collapsed yes uh
politicians uh
boris johnson uh kiyostama lots of
others all piled in
two players and managers but what was
most impressive was the
the solidarity of the fans particularly
in those six clubs who
arguably had something to to gain but
what will happen now will boris johnson
want
to try and reform the ownership and
control management of clubs give fans a
greater say
change the regular regime so this can't
happen again
or will the older tony and rugby man
just go back
uh doing what he normally does which is
a signaling without
uh acting i fear it's going to be the
latter and he's going to miss
a golden opportunity to put fan power in
place
all of the time but andrew that the
groveling apologies from the owners that
the tanking share price the the the over
the overwhelming flow of negative press
that these individuals have got
i'm am i mind after am i missing
something or does it turn out that
billionaires might not be quite as good
at business as we all thought
yeah maybe that's that's a very good
point neil um weasel words from that
ridiculous man who owns liverpool
football club
no comprehension of the fans no
comprehension of the history of
liverpool football club i think i
probably know i know nothing about
football as you know but i think i even
know more
about the cop and liverpool than that
stupid american
who owns liverpool football club weasel
words they they
they're only apologizing because they've
been caught out it's going to be
interesting to see isn't it if
fans stay away uh when when the crowds
are allowed back if they stop buying
the overpriced football shirts that
these gretchen clubs
bring out every year and and how they
rip people off with all the merchandise
i think it's a real been a real wake-up
call for premier league football and
actually ask for the prime minister
but one who's not we know he's not a
football fan but i think he got stuck
into this very well right at the very
beginning
he was onto it straight away on sunday
put out a statement condemning it and i
think that made a big difference at the
the cabinet the culture secretary oliver
dowden got stuck into and they realized
very quickly
these football owners that they were
onto a losing wicket if i can mix the
metaphor there
i don't know stuck into the
ownership of gloves it's difficult isn't
it but
i think it would be a very popular thing
for him to do and i think he's done his
his popularity no harm at all
in some of those red wall seats with his
sterling defense of premier league
football
kevin let's go to the front of the daily
telegraph and the prime minister's
admittedly on this story as well was
very quick out of the blocks very quick
out of the blocks to say
as regards those text messages from
james dyson that he's got nothing to
apologize for and he stands by at all
but an interesting development in the
telegraph story
yeah they say that uh james dyson has
moved his uh main address to the uk
uh he went to singapore two years ago uh
uh but now he's got an address and
company records in the uk
reading this piece i'm not quite clear
that he pays tax in
the the uk uh maybe he does maybe maybe
he doesn't because if you
uh abroad you can still uh spend quite a
few days
in the uk but it was controversial given
that he backed brexit in particular
when he then moved his uh zhq
uh to uh to to asia but um
certainly the the leak of those
uh those text messages and how they came
out i'm sure there's a story in there
but it did show a certain coziness
between boris johnson
and uh and james dyson which let's face
it if you're an
nhs worker only getting one percent or
you're a teacher a police officer or a
soldier getting zero percent to cut your
living standards you haven't you haven't
got access to the prime minister like
that you haven't got his private uh
private number to lobby dyson provided
no
ventilators in the end and that talk of
fixing tax if it was for
for dyson's company or uh dyson's
workers the very fact that all of a
sudden costs were the
forest of dyson's mind in a pandemic
doesn't
make the swashbuckling intervention look
as noble as it might appeared
a year ago and it drags the prime
minister into what is becoming a pretty
wide
sleaze a sort of choice stretching
um friendship relaxing tory boy just
about
aesthetic i always like this
light the blue touch paper and stand
well back there you go it's
pathetic it's pathetic of maguire to go
down that route
and the leader of the opposition should
just grow up it's entirely proper
for one of our most famous successful
entrepreneurs
to text a prime minister to say if his
staff come back to britain
uh to assist in the great great project
to
get all those uh ventilators made
the ventilator challenge described as
one of the greatest procurement programs
by a labour controlled committee of mps
it's entirely
right for him to say to lobby the prime
minister or somebody in government to
say
they shouldn't have to pay tax credits
others might suggest that
others might suggest that the
billionaire james dyson might have been
able to stick his own hands in his own
pockets
well hang on hang on neil um he was 20
000 pounds out of pocket on this whole
project anyway
but all the changes were put to
parliament and they applied to doctors
and engineers
coming back to britain to help out with
covid and it was for a three-month
period
entirely plausible there's nothing
sleazy about it uh dyson meg
got no personal benefit out of it and i
think it's pretty
desperate stuff for starmer whose poll
ratings are tanking so badly
if he thinks this is going to stick
people will see this was an effort
by a businessman to try and build
ventilators which we badly needed
uh and the prime minister was trying to
support that and i think that's a noble
noble thing for both of them to be doing
let's see if we can get before sorry i
just want to squeeze in one more story
kevin before we get to the break um i i
want to see if we can get a rare moment
of accord between the two of you
at the front page of the sun at europe
we could all be heading there on our
holidays
very very soon we could costa bravo
there it's like
greece spain portugal want uh want
tourists
and grant chaps the transport secretary
has said that they may
treat the islands and in those uh
of those countries and differently to
the mainland because the
covert rates are lower on the on the
island so it may be possible a test
before you go a test when you come back
rather than quarantine we'll find out uh
shortly because i think it's may 17
uh holidays have become legal again
absolutely incredible that uh that
they're
illegal at the moment uh i think a lot
of people want to get away
i think uh they understand about a year
of sacrifice
increasing number of people are
vaccinated and they quite like a break
andrew are you packing the budgie
smugglers anytime soon
you know i'm not actually i've decided
i'm seeing those reports that the
airports are experiencing
queues of six to seven hours currently
and airports are only at five percent
capacity
the thought of that fills you with
absolute dread so it's a staycation this
year
i'm just gonna have to absolutely make
sure that whichever county i'm in that
kevin mcguire isn't there at the same
time
he can go abroad you're really
publishing britain most people have
looked forward to you being away at
least two weeks of the year
now it's going to be a full 52 week late
summer a lot longer and gloomer than it
would have been otherwise by state
right chaps you pause there we'll talk
to you in a second coming up after the
break you're either going to love this
story or you will hate it we will be
discussing
an apparent shortage of marmite after
the break all the big stories here on
sky news
i think the story about titanic is is
really been one of glamour for the most
part
for most of the last century and only
recently have we turned our attention to
the third class
passengers which are really sort of the
most the most interesting when you think
about the most diverse
um and and in some ways the most
mysterious and for us the chinese
passengers
they really represented the the the
forgotten passengers in third class
they were there their story just wasn't
known it wasn't
easy to find uh there weren't many
records
and there were a lot more glamorous
targets
so if you're going to invest your time
into titanic research they were probably
pretty low on the list
but as we found it was it was quite a
quite an interesting story they were
they were really the easiest to blame
they were the most foreign of all of
uh titanic's foreign passengers
um there was the anti the the chinese
exclusion act on
at the time in the united states and it
was just very easy to blame them it was
very easy to
turn to these men who had survived and
say
oh well what are they doing here when uh
so many other men so many other husbands
and
and sons and fathers had died on board
titanic so immediately they were
suspected of having acted ignobly
um you know when when others had gone
down with the ship
more than anything it was a reaction of
surprise because they really didn't know
very much their their ancestors had not
shared very much with them at all
because it was
a shameful experience for them because
they were vilified afterwards
um they they were not quick to share any
details about it and in fact
uh in the case of of one survivor the
one
whose story we're able to tell most
completely he didn't even know his
father had been on titanic
until well after he died so it was
definitely a voyage of discovery not
only for us but but for them as well
everyone can find something
that they want us they can find
themselves in the titanic story
if you're wealthy you can find yourself
in there if you feel like you would act
uh nobly on the night that you would
give way on the night
you can find yourself there if you think
you were would have been an immigrant
and down in third class
you can find yourself there as well and
now we're just very pleased that
you know so many fans of the film and so
many fans of the story in china
can find themselves in it now